[Music]
hi everyone i'm priyanka ricaria
developer advocate on the google cloud
team and today i'm going to show you how
to use vertex ai and help a friend get
into yoga
we are building a yoga pose
classification model let's get started
first thing we need is the data for this
step
my friend sarah and i collected a bunch
of images from our yoga practice and
uploaded them into the managed datasets
as you see here the images are labeled
in five categories
i can even upload unlabeled images and
label them
we can analyze our dataset to see that
we have enough examples of each
categories
now we are ready to train our model in
here
i'm selecting automl for training method
you can also train a model to deploy on
the edge or on-premise
or use custom training if you're writing
your own custom model code
now we define our model
automl automatically splits the data
into training validation
and test but we can change it if you
want to
in compute and pricing we get to select
how many node hours we want to train the
model
at this point we wait for the model to
train
once it is trained we see it in the
model tab and can evaluate the model
we can see our model's average precision
it ranges from 0 to 1
where a higher value indicates a higher
quality model
we can see that the confusion matrix
helps us understand
where our model is confusing to results
now that we have evaluated our model
it's time to deploy it to an endpoint
we can split traffic between two models
deployed on the same endpoint if needed
allocate the number of nodes needed for
this endpoint
depending on where your users are select
the region to deploy your endpoint
and that's it hit deploy and we have an
endpoint
now we can test our endpoint and the
model by uploading an
image and yay it works
you can also make predictions using the
sdk
if this has piqued your interest in
vertex ai and you want to learn more
head over to the documentation linked on
screen thanks for watching